head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
let's jump to this uh next Twitter story
Elon Musk he says Twitter has had a
massive drop in Revenue due to activist
groups pressuring advertisers even
though nothing has changed with content
moderation and we did everything we
could to appease the activists extremely
messed up they're trying to destroy free
speech in America now this is funny
Elon Musk himself was fact checked it
says multiple advertisers have confirmed
they are pausing spending while they see
what direction Elon Musk takes the
platform the growing Exodus of
advertisers comes amid concerns musk
will scale back misinformation and
security protections on the platform
which he did Hank Green famous YouTuber
says you tweeted a conspiracy theory
from a website less credible than the
National Enquirer like four days ago we
all need to look inward as well as
outward Elon responds and therefore
Twitter should die and Hank says of
course not it's just it's too simple to
attribute this to I love how he put it's
just dot dot dot as if he's talking like
why would you do that it's too simple to
attribute this to activists when
advertisers are given reasons to be
cautious you wield a lot of power and it
would be very good for Twitter for you
to do it more thoughtfully Hank these
people publicly came out various media
organizations and told Twitter
they are I'm sorry they told the
advertisers to pull their ads from
Twitter until Elon makes guarantees so
this was like I think it was Media
Matters a few other organizations they
the activists actually publicly went to
the advertisers and got them to pull
their heads so it's just like you know
Elon Musk has Hank try a Google search
seriously what was he talking about oh
Elon Musa do I didn't get the if you
Google search activists are pulling ads
from Twitter you will see numerous high
profile mainstream stories of big
activist groups telling advertisers to
pull their ads off Twitter Elon tweets
that's happening and Hank says you can't
attribute this to activists the
advertisers have real concerns like no
it was literally activists who who wrote
the letters and sent this right away
yeah even according to the foundation
for freedom online they came out with a
report detailing how specific
individuals specifically uh Bill Gates
were the ones pouring millions of
dollars into dark money funds to attack
Elon Musk to make sure that advertisers
pull ads out of Twitter and today we're
seeing General Mills Audi Pfizer of all
companies
from Twitter yes what are we going to do
I say I say boycott but there's one I'm
gonna read this Elon Musk says regarding
Twitter's reduction in force
unfortunately there is no choice when
the company is losing over four million
dollars a day everyone exited was
offered three months of severance which
is fifty percent more than legally
required it's true but I just wanna I
just wanna I kind of want to bask in
this if you guys want to just feel the
emotion angry leftists
started screaming at advertisers to get
them to drop Twitter and then Elon had
to fire them because he no longer had
the money to pay their salaries so I
just want to make sure I really
reiterate that they got fired because of
themselves that's just it's wonderful to
see they cost themselves their jobs
that's exactly right they literally cost
themselves their jobs so now they're
going to go home and they're going to
cry and they're going to demand the
government give the money
congratulations
what do you do when people don't learn
right I think the eight dollars a month
tactic is wise because you want to get
away from investors well not you do what
you want to get away from investors you
want to get away from advertisers you
don't want to let other corporations run
your corporation or decide your things
you got to do so I'm fully on board with
this Eight dollar a month well you never
you know quote bite the hand that feeds
you and when it comes to Big Pharma when
it comes to Pfizer they sponsor a lot of
news reports they sponsor a lot of media
organizations they sponsor a lot of
social media organizations which I think
is fair to say and criticize right now
that that it affects their coverage
their curation of that particular
company that keeps pouring in millions
and millions of dollars into these
platforms that that does result in
favorable coverage for them so going
back to tribunals yeah so so overall
this is this is a a great thing that yes
advertisers are showing themselves
they're showing their true colors
they're saying hey we don't stand by
Free Speech we don't stand by something
that we can't control we can't curate
towards our personal benefit you have
increased speech is a threat to us so
we're going to shut this down and we're
going to make sure that we're going to
publicly take ads off of Twitter to try
to bring it all down so I I think it's
clear as day what's happening right now
and I think that eight dollar you know a
month model is something that's going to
fight against a lot of this bull crap
and why I said from the beginning I
would support it I would pay for it
especially if Elon Musk keeps his
promise and only when frees the unbanned
people yes dude my attitude is when he
unbans the political prisoners then I'm
going to sign right up and be like thank
you good sir it's a good product I was
so ready to gamify this website with
avatars that you can buy with tokens and
get them outfits and stuff I was just
looking over my documents uh the systems
that I've built for this Elon let us do
it dude let's go I think uh mostly based
off of how mines does it my proposal was
when you sign up for Twitter every
account is defaulted in the top level
safer work mode meaning any post that's
not safe for work is blurred out unless
you click on it to reveal what that post
is but no Shadow bands if you're
following someone and they're and and
their post is It Breaks the Rules it
gets just blurred and then you have to
choose it'll say this post broke the
safer work rules and maybe not safe for
work you click it Twitter actually has
something like this but you don't need
to suspend or ban people if the rule
break is like hate speech or whatever or
maybe like it's something some kind of
offensive thing
so the way I see it is if you break the
rules you're a single individual post is
blurred if you break the rules three
times your whole account is default into
the second tier not safer work category
people can go into their accounts and
put always show me not say for work
posts and then everyone is identical or
they can stay in the safe work mode and
then every post from you will still
appear in their feed with your name but
they have to click it to see it that way
advertisers don't appear next to it
unless the person chooses to have it
appear next to them that's not company's
fault more importantly if someone lands
in not safer work mode from violating
the rules you can have it be that ads
don't appear next to these posts it's
that simple and then when you get put
into this filtered mode it lasts
depending on the severity of the of the
rule break between one and three months
unless you commit a crime then you are
off the platform depending on the
severity of the crime for as long as the
punishment of that crime is so like
basically if you commit a crime you go
to prison we get rid of your account
once you're out of prison and paid your
debt then you get your account back
it'll be not safe not say for work mode
for three months and then is restored
and then someone said what about people
who are already banned all of their
accounts instantly get reactivated but
are in not safe for work mode for three
months and then instantly restored to a
normal account no Shadow Banning no
algorithmic restrictions the only
changes it's blurred or it's not and
someone can just click it and it on
blurs
good move yeah mines has a lot of that
implemented already with another exact
work stuff yeah but but the problem is
this isn't about that for Twitter the
problem is they want you gone if you say
something like communism is bad they
want you gone who's they like the
establishment left the cult they just
destroyed their own jobs they would
rather see Twitter explode than lose
this political power you saw this kind
of play out over the debate over blue
check marks right uh the the there is
something deeply offensive about the
idea of people being able to buy one as
opposed to them being awarded based on
what is essentially Prestige Maddie
glacias I think is one of the worst
analysts of our time uh did this thread
and he argued the opposite he's like
trust me journalists don't think that
the blue check is prestigious why are
they freaking out over this no no no no
I can tell you for a fact having worked
advice absolutely it was like when I
when I started advice people asked me
like oh do you want to get verified
they're like let's put in a call make it
happen yeah and that's literally I think
what they did was they emailed and then
I was verified boom like that yeah it's
a social status and personality
absolutely and they Lord it over you but
but it's not even that we had I think it
might have been fresh and fit I'm not
sure if it was them but they said when
you're verified on Instagram you're you
get DMS you DM you DM a woman on
Instagram and you're verified it's like
you get a date the verification everyone
knows what it means these journalists
only like a year ago actually one guy
recently tweeted I'm verified on Twitter
with 30 000 followers don't f with me
and he was like talking about it's a
product like some company did him wrong
and so then his response was I am
verified with followers and I will they
absolutely view it as a status 100 100
as a social media developer it is so
funny to watch people obsess over their
social media stuff because it is uh
you're a button click away from being
zeroed out just so you know when you use
social media Stephen King what did he
say that they should be paying us at
least he's right though they should be
and elon's agreed to do it so Twitter is
one of the only platforms it doesn't pay
its top creators so that's a good point
yeah I I they started showing you view
count on your tweets on mobile or
whatever and it's like my tweets get
hundreds of thousands of views or
whatever so
Twitter is relying on me to generate
interest in being on the platform and
then I get nothing for it that's why
they did the verification thing because
it was a way to not pay people but trick
them to be active on the platform yeah
right I mean it worked I mean and you
see how taking it away from them is
making them so angry I I agree with it I
love the idea I I it's gonna be awesome
so one of the challenges with
verification the reason why they made it
exclusive was because they couldn't
afford to to look at everyone's ID
there's just too many people
charging eight bucks Elon can hire
people to actually do the verification
process and then what you do when you
get verified is like you show an ID in a
credit card or something something like
I think it's like an ID for me because
Vice did it Vice just said you're good
and they said yes but there are other
people who like you'll wake up one day
and it'll be like hey we're verifying
you because hey it's happening and oh
and then they ask you to send your ID or
something to prove it I say anyone can
do it
if you have a business you just submit
plain as day and then we know your
business is the official account because
someone at Twitter confirmed your
account that's all it means it's just
verifying the official account so that
if you see another Tim pool they know
that you're the one that has the check
mark that's the point and then you don't
need to appease advertisers you have
advertisers sure great but you don't
need them you're not dependent on them
you're you know Pfizer in uh 2021 they
spent two billion dollars on
advertisement that's right a lot of
money not on Twitter just just in
general I gotta say too uh to be honest
I did an ad for will of the people and
it had really great impact I was
impressed on Twitter yeah yeah yeah it
it traveled off of Twitter got millions
of hits for not that much money and then
I ended up seeing results on other
platforms from people who had heard the
song and I was like wow it's actually
I'm kind of surprised because I thought
Twitter would be bad let's do it again
I'm sure Elon would appreciate that
we're watching now imagine what two
billion dollars does oh for sure I mean
I think I think we did like five I think
it was like five grand in ads and we've
got like millions of vets I was I was
shocked by that that's crazy and uh we
we are doing with the new song with
genocide we are doing we have a company
handling it so I don't know exactly
what's going on but they they sent me
like here's the things we're going to be
running and I'm like yeah do whatever
but I'm looking forward to it
um with Elon Musk coming out and doing
this stuff it's a good sign I'm totally
down for advertising on Twitter I will
sign up for Twitter blue the moment he
actually unbans the political prisoners
because otherwise it's just like you
know dude don't don't it's Jack Dorsey
all over again he told me to my face
we're going to create a path to
Redemption and then he never did that
they never had any interest in doing it
and it's it's insane because
why not just let Milo come back on the
platform like no seriously why not be
like hey you were banned for six months
we're sending this email to let you know
we're gonna restore your account and
we're asking you to follow these rules
if you don't follow the rules we will
just have to ban you again we're hoping
that you agree and then they'd get a
power user back but they're it's
ideologically driven they just want the
political victim but Jack was you know a
symbol and and Jack also didn't get rid
of the human rights team
so so you know props to him because
again everyone's freaking out the human
rights they don't understand what the
team actually did the larger effects of
it and it was a net negative to everyone
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time